what do you think is the future of the
fitness industry any trends that you can
see growing or falling away the
bodybuilding stuff is starting to descip
but we still have this massive wave of
dishonesty it is Led unfortunately by a
lot of brand deals people are clowing up
to the BS a bit more now evidence-based
stuff seems to be coming more to the
Forefront and there's a lot of
ideological people if you go to a
supermarket and pick something up off a
shelf and going this is suddenly
people like oh why we've got all of
these people chat and waffling
supermarkets Kale's bad for you fasting
is going to stop you ever getting cancer
all of these things veganism had its
wave carnivore is actually still alive
because of Joe Rogan ideology is still
pretty Rife unfortunately a lot of
people in a bid to remain active on
social media to get views on social
media views and interactions on social
media is how people are obtaining the
levels of self-proclaimed status status
is what all of us are trying to get
drunk of so many people now getting
their first taste of status on Tik Tok
social media whatever and they're doing
it through being extreme that being
ideological and by tapping into people's
pre-existing beliefs that often aren't
true